how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
something rather
interesting has come to surface we have
a leak for the black
widow movie today and not just a plot
leak but a leak
for the entire film including a mid
and post credit scene now this is posted
by somebody who has claimed to have
worked on the film
now there's no way for us to tell if
this is real or
fake there have been plenty of plot
leaks and plenty of leaks about movies
that end up being
true and this leak about the movie
happens to be very detailed and it lines
up with some things that we've heard in
the past before
about the film so for the sake that this
may very well be true
we're going to cover this plot leak
today so if you are trying to avoid
any and all possible spoilers for the
black widow film you should click away
from this video
now and if you're still with me and
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
mcu and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a hawkeye
funko pop
all you have to do to enter is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and leave a comment down below
so let's dive into this plot leak for
the entire black widow film
including the two post credit scenes
we'll skip over this person's personal
opinion about the film but he did
compare it to john wick
which means that it's gonna have pretty
decent action in it
so it starts off by saying the movie
opens with robert downey jr's voice over
a time card setting up that it's right
at the end of civil war
tony tells natasha that she needs to run
because they're gonna come after her the
hardest due to her past
she gets on a motorcycle and drives away
from the avengers facility
and we get the more of a logo the next
scene is a flashback to young nat
she's talking with young elena in a
hallway she's been asked to kill a
diplomat and she's unsure if she can do
it
she tries but can't bring herself to
pull the trigger she goes out into the
hallway and cries the woman leading the
red room
leads elena in and through an opaque
glass door we see her shoot the man
without a thought
back in the present time when the movie
is set right after civil war natasha
goes to budapest
she's looking for something to make her
and captain america and sam
be untraceable there's a voice over of
sam as she relays info to him
she knows that yelena can find it
because the red room used to use it for
its widows natasha tracks jelena down to
her apartment
they fight and then once they know that
they're not going to kill each other
they have a beer
they talk about guilt they bond yelena
tells nat that she can't give her the
device because the red room still has it
drake cobb has started up a new program
and started training
new widows now quick note here drakov
was mentioned in the very first avengers
film when loki was talking to black
widow
and it's very evident when black widow
is talking about the red in her ledger
that she either killed drakov's daughter
or did something
very very bad to her so this is the
drakov that the leak is talking about
we then see another flashback that shows
a slightly older natasha which is a
de-aged scarlett johansson
something that marvel is known for doing
escaping the red room program
it's run by ray winston and he's got his
daughter with him who isn't a part of
the program
she does a bunch of spy stuff to escape
but she gets caught by
drakoff she says something about always
being taught to shoot first and tries to
kill him
but he attacks her and somehow she
shoots something that makes the hallway
explode seemingly killing drakov and his
young daughter who was hiding behind him
natasha survives by jumping out of a
window into a river
her underwater face transitions to her
in a bathtub in yelena's apartment
they have beef over the fact that
natasha abandoned her and never came
back when suddenly they're attacked by
taskmaster and his goons
taskmaster puts up a really good fight
basically defeating the two of them but
they do manage to escape
they decide they need to find out who
taskmaster is and who he's working for
and also
in the red room program for good they
travel to the swiss alps to find molina
who was an older widow who was kind of
motherly to them
she's retired living a quiet life and is
happy to see them
she knows that the red room is active
and that the new widows are being
trained by a mysterious mercenary called
taskmaster his ability to memorize the
fighting styles of others makes him
invaluable to the program
she reluctantly agrees to help them take
him down but they all concede they'll
need help
we see taskmaster in a command center
he's watching footage of nat fight from
the movies we've seen
also watching footage of elena dracov's
voice over and intercom gives orders to
the widows to follow his orders and let
him teach them
he takes on several widows at once and
easily defeats them
drakov tells them to do better meanwhile
in siberia we get the most fun sequence
of the movie
natasha elena and molina all do a full
fun
spy movie charlie's angel style prison
break to get alexi
their father slash big brother figure
out of a russian state prison
they succeed in breaking him out they
have a little family reunion and then we
cut to scenes as natasha as a young
teenager again
they go to an old red room facility but
they don't find anything as it's empty
molina hacks an old computer that's got
a list of the program's safe houses on
it they head to the most likely one
trying to find dracov and taskmaster is
secretly watching them
while crossing a border they are
captured by cia agent
rick mason and we find out that him and
natasha used to be together
he reveals that he's working for
thunderbolt ross directly to bring them
back home
ross and widow make a deal that if mason
accompanies them the whole way
and she turns herself in after they'll
be allowed to continue
shutting the red room down we see a
flashback of a younger ross and a
younger natasha making a similar deal
when she's recruited into shield
ross wanted her for her own reasons but
he says something along the lines of
fury always gets what he wants ever
since he saved the world from aliens
they go to the other safe house it's
empty but it's a big
trap explosions separate them all
there's a giant fight that breaks out
and taskmaster shoots at them with the
bow and arrow
hawkeye style nat escapes on her own and
goes to a bridge where they all plan to
meet up after
but taskmaster is waiting for her this
fight really shows off taskmaster's
fighting style and how we can copy
other avengers natasha actually manages
to crack taskmaster's helmet by landing
a blow to him and she jumps off the
bridge to escape
shortly after yelena appears then mason
then molina and then
alexi mason and nat tend to each other's
wounds at a campsite
they kiss but nat pulls away and says
she doesn't have the best of luck with
men
she says my last boyfriend flew away
into space
obviously referring to the hulk slash
bruce banner mason agrees and says that
his last girlfriend literally
shot him in the head and he shows her
his scar the next morning as they
prepare to leave
taskmaster attacks them he seemingly
kills mason with his sword and nat is
devastated but yelena makes her leave
with them
molina was scouting ahead in the city
and she comes back and comforts her
telling her the story
of how she had a husband and a daughter
who died nat
is shocked to learn that she had a child
and molina says that the sterilization
procedure didn't work on her and that
she had to hide the fact that she was
pregnant
by faking that she was a prisoner of war
saying we all do crazy things for our
family
this leads us to the big finale in the
mountains that we've seen in the trailer
the black widows taskmaster and his
goons and red guardian all duking it out
there's some kind of bio weapon that's
about to be launched with this crane as
the red
room's current mission taskmaster and
red guardian have a pretty big fight and
taskmaster
kills him in front of yelena molina and
natasha
molina holds them off while natasha and
yolina fight their way inside to where
they think drakov
is turns out he isn't it's a computer
that is changing somebody's voice to
sound like drakov's voice
and it turns out that it's molina her
and drakov were in love and they had a
daughter together and natasha killed
both of them taskmaster is then revealed
to be mason
he tells natasha that she trusts too
easy and that he just works for the
highest bidder
molina was pissed that taskmaster killed
alexi but
he justified it by saying that he was in
the way of my target
and as it turns out it was molina
wearing the taskmaster suit when mason
was apparently
killed but of course it was fake the
four of them fight and molina escapes to
go and put on some armor
they end up being surrounded by all the
widows and taskmaster says that he's one
however yelena and natasha end up
convincing the widows to fight with them
they overwhelm taskmaster by attacking
him all at once
natasha and yelena end up using each
other's moves to confuse taskmaster and
it works
they finally defeat him and they have
him on his knees but natasha won't kill
him
but elena doesn't hesitate and she
shoots him through a crack and his mask
yelena tells natasha to go nat's
bleeding and her suit is cut open so
yelena gives her her vest and says
she'll see her on the other side
natasha and molina have a one-on-one
showdown
nat is overpowered by the advancements
of melina's suit
but remembering the training that melina
herself taught her
outsmarts her and uses her widow bites
to short-circuit the suit
nat says that killing drakov's daughter
has haunted her for 20 years
that she never meant for it to happen
she gives molina a chance to forgive her
but
she doesn't and natasha ends up pushing
her off of a ledge
falling to her death after natasha and
yolina meet up
they hug goodbye and natasha tries to
give her vest back but yelena says that
she doesn't want it now because nat got
her stink all over it she then smiles
and says it looks better on you anyways
yolina feels bad that their whole family
fell apart and died but natasha says
that this made her realize that she
already had a family worth dying for
the avengers natasha offers elena a
chance to come with her but yelena says
that saving the world isn't her thing
but natasha points out that they just
did yelena smiles and says well that was
a one-off and then she rides away
the last scene of the movie is natasha
realizing that yelina stole
the impossible tracking device gadget
from her when they hugged goodbye
and it ends with natasha smiling to
herself then we have the first
post-credit scene which is one that we
have heard before it's a vilena walking
into a dark warehouse
a bunch of soldiers pointing guns at her
she casually puts her hands up and
throws the device on the table
sitting at the table is thunderbolt ross
taskmaster is there and yelena gets
pissed saying that
he killed her friend and that wasn't
part of the plan he takes off his helmet
to reveal a bandage and points out that
she returned the favor
by shooting him in the head but she then
points out that it's
not the first time that she's done that
revealing that it was her that mason was
talking about to natasha
she says to thunderbolt ross i think
that relieves me of our deal and ross
responds
oh no we're just getting started the
final post-credit scene is a very
emotional scene with clint and his
family
looking at the grave of natasha so
that's the plot leak for
the black widow film and the two post
credits scenes which we've heard before
now there's a lot to this plot leak that
does seem very legitimate it's
very detailed and a lot of things do
make a lot of sense but of course having
said that that does not mean that this
is 100 true but if this is the way that
the black widow movie is going to go
what do you think about it would you be
happy with how
the movie is let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below
also don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the marvel
cinematic universe for live updates you
can follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof